what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the falcon and the winter soldier
episode 2 did not disappoint there is a
lot to break down in this video and many
things
are very very important not only for
this show moving forward but for the
marvel cinematic universe moving forward
as well so i suggest you watch the
entire video because a lot of important
things actually happen towards the end
and i'll get to it in my shot by shot
breakdown
but like usual i will start with a
theory of what i actually think is
really happening here but of course
before we start if you love marvel be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos
well as expected as i mentioned in my
last video the flax smashers are indeed
super soldiers
they have stolen from a huge
organization called the grc
and are now in trouble with somebody
called the power broker now the power
broker in the comics is actually a
company that will give
people the super soldier serum if they
pay for it so the power broker could be
how all of these members of the flag
smashers are super soldiers but the
power broker also said
you stole from me and as we know the
flag smashers stole from the grc
so the power broker must be in charge of
the grc as well and the leader of the
flag smashers carly
said that people who were in charge and
in power before the blip were put
back into power after the blip by these
big organizations
now a person that was in power that
comes to my mind is thunderbolt
ross we've seen thunderbolt ross for a
very long time in the marvel cinematic
universe ever since the incredible hulk
he has been working on
super soldier serums in fact he is even
responsible for the weapon plus
program this has been an infatuation of
his since the incredible hulk
and as you know he's been very involved
in the mcu ever since
he is responsible for the sokovia
accords he wanted to control the
avengers which eventually led to them
tearing apart he then even tried to
arrest half of the avengers so clearly
he was a person
in power and clearly he has been working
with the super soldier serum and
clearly he is a crooked guy so my theory
is that he is actually in charge of the
grc
and he is the power broker as well since
he is trying to perfect
his super soldier serum he could have
used the flax smashers as
experiments the serum ended up working
on them and they used that to actually
steal from him they could have actually
been working for him but then went rogue
we know that thunderbolt ross is going
to be in the black widow movie which was
supposed to release before the falcon in
the winter soldier and as far as the mcu
timeline is concerned it takes place
before the events of the falcon and the
winter soldier it actually takes place
before the events of avengers infinity
war and it's highly believed that black
widow is going to explore super soldier
serum as well
we believe that those red vials in the
black widow trailer is the serum and
it's being given to the girls in the red
room and that's why thunderbolt ross is
in black widow
so my theory is that thunderbolt ross is
behind
all of this and will eventually be
revealed in the falcon in the winter
soldier series perhaps at the very end
i also believe that eventually the new
captain america john walker will be
given a version of a super soldier serum
he's already shown
signs of not being so good despite his
record of being an actual hero but
thunderbolt ross loves to control those
superheroes so perhaps i'll end up
giving him some serum as well
sending him over the edge and let's talk
about that right now
in my shot by shot breakdown the first
scene starts with the new captain
america that was announced and the
ending of the last episode and in the
beginning we're led to believe that jon
is actually a really good guy
a stand-up guy and a good soldier it
begins with him pulling the zipper down
on the coat bag that contains his new
captain america uniform and we find out
that he's actually at his old high
school
custer's grove high school custer's
grove is u.s
agents john walker's hometown and he is
about to attend a parade and celebration
for him and be on the good morning
america show and he's reminiscing in the
locker room of the times when he used to
play football he even finds that his
name is still
on his old locker removing the current
owner of the locker's name to see his
jw10 of course jw is john walker and his
number must have been 10.
his wife comes in and talks about how
she'd sneak in to see him before the
game so it's clear that they're high
school sweethearts who stuck together
which actually says a lot about him as a
person
seems like he's loyal he served his
country and he was apparently the number
one pick to be the new captain america
and it makes you wonder why he's such a
jerk later on in the episode
but we talked about that a little bit in
the beginning of this video his wife
leaves and then comes in lamar
hoskins who in the comics takes on the
mantle of bucky and then
battlestar which is revealed to be his
name his superhero name that is later on
in this episode
john walker and lamar hoskins were
friends and before john walker was
captain america in the comics he was
super patriot
john walker wanted to be captain america
so his friend lamar hoskins and two
other men formed a group called the
buckies and they staged attacks that
super patriot could fort off to make him
look good when john walker finally
became captain america in the comics he
wanted hoskins with him and so he became
the next bucky
however hoskins was later told that the
term bucky was demeaning to african
americans
and he was convinced to change his name
to battlestar lamar reveals that just
two weeks before becoming the new
captain america and battlestar they were
doing special ops missions
so it really does seem like they're good
guys they talk about doing the job
doing a good job but he does mention
that jon can't just punch his way out of
problems anymore
this implies that jon may not be that
much of a level-headed guy
that he may be more of a shoot first ask
questions later type of guy now this
combined with a super soldier serum
could
definitely lead to trouble and in this
episode we kind of begin to see that
although it's not confirmed that he has
any type of super soldier serum inside
of him so he goes through the captain
america praise
signs autographs and he takes pictures
and there's already captain america
action figures of him that we see him
signing we get a great look at the new
captain america logo on the football
field which is sort of an a
inside of a star this is actually pretty
similar to his logo in the comics
notice a good majority of the fans in
the stands are actually wearing shirts
with the new captain america logo on it
and it looks like this is very similar
to the original captain america being
introduced it was more of a pr
stunt in the beginning to help people
get excited and hopeful again
and this doesn't seem too different as
the good morning america interview
starts we find out that john walker
really is a stand-up guy and
a hero he was the first person in
american history to receive
three medals of honor he ran rs-1
missions in counter-terrorism and
hostage rescue
and is apparently some sort of a super
soldier without being a super soldier
at least that we know so far he does
state that he doesn't have super
strength but he does seem to have a
handle on that shield as we see him
practicing
throwing the shield in a very captain
america way as we cut to sam and bucky
we see more propaganda posters for the
new captain america just like the old
captain america had a ton
of propaganda posters now obviously sam
and bucky
are not happy about this they're not
happy about there being a new captain
america that isn't sam
because the old captain america steve
rogers gave the shield to sam
it was meant for him to be the new
captain america and bucky makes it known
to sam
how upset he is claiming that he had no
right to give up that shield
however sam is on a mission he thinks
that the flag smashers could be super
soldiers
stating that they're too strong and he
thinks they could be part of the big
three androids aliens and wizards but of
course deep down he knows that they are
super soldiers
in fact in the last scene in the first
episode torres asked him
you don't think they could be and then
he gets cut off but he was talking about
super soldiers he even tells bucky they
use brute force
just like you and of course we soon find
out that they indeed are super soldiers
and from here on out bucky and sam
become
a dysfunctional team and bucky joins sam
on his mission
sam and bucky fly into munich and we get
a feel for how their relationship is
going to be
bucky is used to captain america who
usually had a plan
and sam is definitely not like that he
does not have a plan which is why bucky
says that sam
can't call him bucky because that's what
steve called him and steve had a plan
now falcon jumps out of the plane and if
you notice when he jumps out you can
hear
a repulsor blast or at least a sound
that sounds
just like iron man's repulsor blast and
as they mentioned in the first
episode falcon's gear his suit is stark
level technology and i do believe that
his suit
is stark technology after hearing this
noise now bucky's not letting sam go by
himself and he asks for a shoot but
since they're too
low he can't parachute out but him being
a super
soldier he doesn't need a parachute and
right before diving out of the plane to
a 200 foot drop he rips off his sleeve
and reveals his new
arm now not much is really known about
it at this point in time but we can
probably assume that it's made out of
vibranium since he was very close with
t'challa and the people of wakanda
and since this takes place six months
after the events of avengers in-game
he's had plenty of time at this point to
revisit wakanda
and sam actually goes on to mention that
he's been in wakanda now it's unclear if
he was talking about the time he spent
in wakanda before avengers infinity war
but he does say look at you you spend a
little time in wakanda and you come out
the white panther which is a funny play
on black panther but of course his
character was
the white wolf and this is a call back
to the black panther post
credit scene where the children in
wakanda wake bucky up and they call him
the white wolf
then again in avengers infinity war
t'challa would himself
call bucky the white wolf so he falls to
the ground after hitting a bunch of
trees and sam's drone
redwing who bucky hates got it all on
video they eventually find the flax
smashers and realize that they are
insanely strong
watching only a couple of people lift
insanely heavy objects
but bucky has a vibranium arm and is a
super soldier and sam
can fly and seemingly has some stark
tech and they think that the flax
masters may have a hostage so the two of
them take off and bucky runs insanely
fast due to the fact that he is a super
soldier
now bucky breaks into one of the convoys
and realizes that they are transferring
medicine and vast scenes we don't know
what they are but on them is the label
for a company that says
grc now grc was a logo that was shown in
the ending credits of the first episode
of the falcon in the winter soldier so
it clearly means something and more on
that in just a bit
we then find out of course that the
hostage is not a hostage but a member of
the flags masters and this whole thing
turned out to be a trap because they
knew
that sam and bucky were following them
then commences a pretty epic fight and
sam and bucky aren't exactly handling
themselves very well
but luckily the new captain america john
walker and the new bucky or
lamar hoskins aka battlestar show up and
help
and it becomes very clear that the flag
smashers are indeed super soldiers as
captain america is throwing the shield
hitting someone the head and they're
walking it off like it wasn't really
anything and these blows to the head by
that shield should definitely kill them
in captain america the new cap
definitely looks like he knows how to
handle that shield it's very clear that
he has been training and a few times it
actually looks like he's throwing the
shield at
bucky bucky has to duck a few times to
avoid the shield in fact at one point in
time he throws it it bounces off
somebody and bucky catches it
john walker immediately takes it back
and we can see how frustrated bucky
is with the fact that the new captain
america is helping him because to him
there's only
one captain america and that is his best
friend steve rogers
now unfortunately none of them even all
together are quite enough to take on
these flag smashers and as falcon
rescues bucky and they land in the field
they realize that yes
those were super soldiers and they
realized that this group is a lot
bigger and more of a threat than they
thought they were now john walker
actually had some good moves as captain
america including throwing his shield
very quickly to save his buddy but in
the scene it actually becomes pretty
apparent that john walker and hoskins
are not super soldiers because despite
john walker throwing the shield in
hand-to-hand combat they were nothing
compared to the flag smashers
sam and bucky make it their mission to
find out where the new super soldier
serum is coming from and sam wants to
know that after 80 years how are there
still super soldiers running around
however he's assuming that these are
super soldiers from 80 years ago and not
new super soldiers which of course i
believe we are going to find out they
are new
john walker and lamar hoskins show up
and offer to give bucky and sam a ride
however
they don't want it at first and you can
really see the hatred of this new
captain america from
bucky he even says just because you have
the shield doesn't mean you're captain
america but john walker says that he's
put in the work he's even jumped on four
grenades
they eventually go into the jeep and we
find out who the grc
is we find out that grc stands for the
global repatriation council
after the blip when people started
appearing again after being missing for
five years this organization helped
people with reactivating citizenship
social security health care basically
offering a lot of resources to help the
world
after the blip and the new captain
america and battlestar as he says his
name is
state that they are responsible for
keeping things stable like handling
violent revolutionaries
people that may go against grc like the
flag smashers now bucky's just not
having it so he decides to get out and
john walker states that he wants to be
the best captain america he can be he's
not trying to replace steve
just be a good cap and he wants captain
america's wingmen
sam and bucky by his side but that
doesn't sit well with sam so he gets out
as well
we then go back to the flag smashers who
have found somewhat of a safe house
now this isn't exactly one of their own
however it is held by somebody who
supports their cause
as revealed on some of the flyers on
some of the doors we find out that this
is an
auto shop some read veer cuff alta autos
which is we buy old cars
so these are normal people who support
the cause of the flag smashers they even
call them freedom fighters and the
person even says that some people are
calling them
robin hood and remember the flag
smashers goal is to get things to how
they were
during the blip they want to get rid of
all of the flags all the identities they
want everybody to be
one and you can see how this can be
appealing to some people and how they
can kind of get a cult following which
they are getting
now here we find out that this
mysterious character that aaron kellyman
has been playing
is carly morgenthau and this is actually
a very cool easter egg because it's kind
of a character switch
because in the comics the flag smasher
was not a group it was an actual person
and the first flag smasher was
carl morgenthau so they just call this
one carly because she's a woman
obviously
now in the mcu in the falcon and the
winter soldier i don't think carly
morgenthau
is the flag smasher i don't think there
is a one
singular flag smasher i think that's
just the name of the group and that this
is a cool easter egg or maybe she is the
leader of
all of this which could be a surprise
seen as how sam thinks that the leader
of this
is the man with the long hair and carly
very well could be the leader because
she is the one who gets the text
and the text is from an unknown private
number and it says you took what was
mine
i'm going to find you and kill you now
this is most likely from who is in
charge of the grc
seeing as how the flag smashers stole
some vaccines from the grc
they later go on to refer to this person
as the power broker
and as i mentioned in the beginning i
think this could be thunderbolt ross
now we don't know if he was dusted or
not but she does go on to say that the
grc put the same people in charge
now who were in charge before the blip
thunderbolt ross was definitely in a
position of very high power
within the government so again i do
think that it could be him
now as we go on it does seem like carly
is in charge because she says that she
needs everybody to commit to them right
then and there because tomorrow
stuff is going down but unfortunately it
looks like we're going to have to wait
until the next episode or maybe even a
couple of episodes to find out what that
is
the next scene is with sam and bucky in
a plane and we actually get the name
drop of sharon carter
now we can see just how upset bucky is
he's pissed we can see him in super deep
thought when sam asks
you all ray and he says let's take the
shield sam
wanting to take back what was rightfully
his best friends and then sam's but
sam explains that it's not exactly so
easy the shield is now government
property and property of john walker and
he explains what happened the last time
that him
and some other avengers went against the
government now sam went to wakanda after
the events of civil war
he didn't really have to deal with the
aftermath of the sokovia accords but
sam did along with captain america and
as he says
sharon carter he says sharon was branded
enemy of the state
and steve and i were on the run for two
years
and what's really interesting about this
is he doesn't actually say
natasha this is because she was actually
only with them part of the time
this is because the black widow movie
takes place after
the events of captain america civil war
but before the events of avengers
infinity war so yes natasha was
kind of on the run with them she was
deemed an enemy as well but she left
sam and steve rogers to go handle the
events which we'll see
in black widow now on the plane bucky
says that there is somebody that sam
needs to meet and they head to baltimore
maryland
and here we get an extremely important
scene
they go up to a door and a young man
answers and we're going to talk about
him in just a little bit but bucky says
they're there to see
isaiah in which he says there's nobody
there by that name and you're not
getting through the door but then bucky
says
tell him the guy from the bar and goyang
is here and that he'll know what it
means goyang is a city in south korea in
the northern part of south korea
and we go in and find out who isaiah is
and how he knows bucky
we go in and we meet isaiah bradley now
in marvel comics isaiah bradley is known
as the black
captain america and he has a very
intense story isaiah was around when
captain america steve rogers was in the
ice
after losing the super soldier serum the
united states army wanted to produce
more super soldiers so they attempted to
reproduce the super soldier serum and
they forcibly recruited isaiah and 300
other african-american soldiers to serve
as test subjects
after all the tests were done only a
handful of men survived isaiah being one
of those so isaiah became a super
soldier
isaiah's last assignment was actually a
suicide mission but before leaving on
the mission he took
a captain america costume and a shield
with him
he would actually survive his mission
thanks to the help of a german freedom
fighter group
and eventually he returned home but when
he got home he was court-martialed and
given life in prison for stealing the
captain america costume and shield
however while he was in jail his wife
faith wrote the president a letter
every month for three years and after 17
years in jail the president
ended up pardoning him isaiah ended up
becoming a legend and a hero
in the black community and that's kind
of what we see here in the falcon in the
winter soldier
his story is a tiny bit different in the
mcu and i'm sure we're going to hear a
lot more about it but we find out that
he was actually
sent by the us government to kill bucky
and this sounds like it was sort of a
suicide mission as well
he states that they figured out which
peninsula bucky was on and they kept
sending people after him
and bucky kept killing them so they sent
isaiah
and buggy actually says that isaiah was
a hero and one that
hydra feared the most along with steve
rogers we find out that isaiah
actually kind of defeated bucky and he
ripped off half of his metal arm
he obviously did not kill him but he
defeated him in battle
bucky says that there are more of you
and me out there
referring to super soldiers however
isaiah does not want to talk about it
and he actually starts to show some of
his strength
throwing a tin container through the
wall we then find out why he is so upset
just like in the comics they put him in
jail but in the mcu they put him in jail
for 30 years
and while he was in jail they did
experiments on him and he says that even
your people
talking to bucky weren't done with him
and he was referring to hydra
as bucky later on explains so not only
did the u.s government do experiments on
him but it looks like hydra did as well
which makes sense because hydra was
secretly infiltrating
shield and the us government now at this
point isaiah is extremely upset
and he tells the two of them to leave in
which case the young man tells them to
get out
now in the comics isaiah had a grandson
eli
eli would go on to become a founding
member of the young avengers and would
become the hero
patriot now he originally lied to the
young avengers telling them that he got
some of his grandfather's dna and super
soldier serum in him but he didn't so
what he started doing was injecting
himself with mutant growth
hormone to give himself super soldier
powers however eventually down the line
during a battle between the cree the
scrolls and the young avengers and new
avengers eli would get
injured trying to save captain america
his grandfather isaiah would then give
him
some of his blood and it worked it saved
his life and after
eli gained the physical attributes and
powers of a real
super soldier and i believe that this
young man in his house is most likely
his son
eli aka patriot and we know that the
young avengers are indeed going to be
coming to the mcu and it looks like we
just met
one of its founding members as they
leave sam is super upset that there was
a black super soldier around that nobody
told him
or the world about and that he's been
around for decades buggy says that
nobody knew and he didn't even tell
steve
and if this already wasn't deep enough
talking about race we dive even deeper
when the cops show up
the cops get there and immediately start
questioning sam they leave bucky alone
in fact they asked bucky if sam is
bothering him they only asked to see
sam's id and they only tell sam to calm
down
eventually bucky says do you know who
this is and the other cop says
these are the avengers now the cop is
pretty embarrassed and doesn't know what
to do but he comes back and it turns out
that bucky is actually the one in
trouble
as it turns out bucky missed a therapy
session which was part of his pardon he
had to go to therapy
and since he missed it he was put under
arrest and he's taken to jail
now once he's at the jail some very
interesting things start happening
sam meets bucky's therapist dr raynor
and he thinks that it's her that got him
out however we find out that it is the
new captain america john walker that got
him out
as it turns out dr raynor and john
walker used to do some field ups
together and john says that bucky is now
going to be done with therapy
and when dr arena asked who authorized
this he said himself
so he has some type of weird power here
he clearly has
a lot of authority this is something
that the original captain america steve
rogers did not really have
he didn't have a ton of authority he was
a soldier so that begs the question
a really important question that is why
does john walker
have this power why does he have this
authority and the even bigger question
who gave it to him i also think that
this could be thunderbolt ross i think
he definitely has his own plans and i
think that he wants to give the super
soldier serum
to john walker and i think this is all
going to come to light very very soon
now in order for bucky to get released
he has to do a therapy session and she
makes sam join and despite a lot of
ridiculousness we actually
find out a lot here we find out the real
reason that bucky is so upset
over sam giving up the shield he said it
represented
everything that steve represented he
says that steve trusted sam
but maybe he was wrong about him and if
he was wrong about sam then maybe steve
was wrong about bucky
and what he's referring to here is bucky
being a good
person as we know a big part of bucky's
life right now is trying to right his
old wrongs that he did as the winter
soldier
he killed a lot of people and a lot of
innocent people including yori's son
and he's now questioning who he is and
if he's good and steve was the person
that was there to tell him that he was
good but steve's not there anymore and
he's doubting himself and he's now
thinking that if steve was wrong about
sam choosing him to be the next captain
america
after him maybe he was wrong about bucky
as well and that bucky isn't actually
good and there's no hope for him now of
course there is but bucky is in a really
hard place
now samden says that giving up the
shield was something that
him or steve could never understand
which leads me to believe that it has to
do with race
in the comics when nick fury recommended
sam wilson be the next captain america
after steve rogers they denied him
stating that the world might not be
ready for a black captain america the
director and the writer of the falcon
and the winter soldier stated many
different times that this show is going
to explore race and if the world
is ready for a black captain america so
this leads me to believe that something
involving racism happened before
sam chose to give up the shield
something that i'm sure we'll find out
relatively soon
sam then proposes that they finish this
mission and then never speak to each
other again in which bucky agrees but we
all know that that's not going to be the
case by the end of the series they leave
and they're greeted by the new captain
america john walker who they absolutely
love
and his partner battlestar john walker
suggests that they work together they
need to track down the flag smashers and
during this conversation you can see
john walker getting more and more
agitated
sam explains that since john walker and
battlestar work for the government they
have rules and regulations and
authorizations that they need to get
before they can actually do a mission
and engage
sam and bucky however are free agents
and they can kind of do whatever they
want so it doesn't make sense to work
together essentially he was saying that
sam and bucky are better off without
john walker
and hoskins and this really pisses off
john walker on a bunch of different
levels it makes him mad that he has to
go through all this authorization that
he talked about and it also makes him
mad that he was rejected so he says stay
the hell out of my way
and we start to see the darker side of
this new captain america which i think
is going to come out a lot more in the
following episodes and i think that john
walker might have a pretty tragic story
in this series now going back to the
flags masters we find out about the
power broker
the power brokers men have found the
flag smashers and as i mentioned i
believe that the power broker is in
charge of the grc
now the power broker in the comics is
kind of an actual person the power
broker corporation was founded by curtis
jackson
and basically what he did was turn
people into super soldiers
for the right price essentially people
could pay him to have a super soldier
serum injected into them but it was very
very risky
and a lot of people died during the
process now in the comics the power
broker corporation was founded by curtis
jackson however in the mcu
i believe it could be founded by
thunderbolt ross we know he's been
working on the super soldier serum and
weapons plus
program ever since the incredible hulk i
believe he is behind the grc and he's
behind the power broker corporation or
calling himself the power broker
attempting to create a perfect super
soldier serum but until we find out we
will simply refer to this person as the
power broker now the power brokers men
eventually find the flag smashers but
one of the flag smashers sacrifices
himself for the greater good and the
rest of them manage to get away
then we have the final scene that sets
up a lot which is to come
bucky explains that when isaiah was
talking about his people he was talking
about hydra they experimented with
super soldiers and now bucky thinks that
they could be behind these super
soldiers as well
and there's one person that knows a ton
about hydra and that
is zemo the person responsible for
framing bucky and also controlling him
via the hydra brainwashing
and also the person responsible for
essentially destroying the avengers as
we saw him do very well in captain
america civil war bucky explains that he
knows all of hydra's secrets and that's
who they need to go see
he is currently in jail after the events
of civil war and we see him
in his cell in the very last shot so in
the next episode the falcon and the
winter soldier episode 2 we are getting
baron zemo and hopefully
sharon carter that's it for this
breakdown be sure to subscribe for
future falcon in the winter soldier
breakdowns as well as
other marvel disney plus shows coming
let me know what you rate this episode
in the comments down below
don't forget to give the video a like
and for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you